yeah this is something that uh
jacques gave me i just had lunch with
him yesterday up at his house and he's
got these book collections sitting
around him and i just get this lust in
my heart for the book collection
um so anyway uh
this is ludwig ludwiger
uh illa brand von ludwiger um and uh
i mean i don't understand the math i
don't even pretend to
uh but um
is he still alive as far as you know no
i think he's dead
but um
so basically this is like almost this is
the end and i don't well according to
this theory he's not dead but yeah
according to stewart but basically this
structure that he draws here at the end
is a a visual representation
of um
of how when
a certain structure is created
the top of it
through these levels of organization
consciousness would form because of it
um and
uh
that then you could take away the
underlying structure
formed it and then this would continue
to exist
okay independently
um which is interesting the reason why i
like this and he didn't really talk
about this he talks about it in the
context of um of uh of biology but
if it's right it means you could create
an artificial intelligence which was in
and of itself
um
would could become conscious
you know most
um
you know scientists working in ai never
think that we will have
the ability to create a conscious i mean
that anything that we create uh that
looks conscious is just a a darn good
simulation
of of uh you know it would pass the
turing test
but it would just be a darn good
simulation
uh
but it's not really conscious um
so you know it so therefore it has no
rights
as far as human rights as far as where
you know it's a big argument that's been
played out in science fiction for for
many years
what this guy is basically saying
and i don't know anything about the math
i just find it interesting i get
interested in these kinds of ideas yeah
that you could create an object
humans might someday be able to without
using biology but using purely
materialistic
uh
approaches
build a sufficiently complex machine
that creates
an object with consciousness and a soul
that's fascinating
you know so he is
go ahead did he say whether or not this
soul would survive
for an indeterminate amount of time yes
yes yes but yeah that's what he's saying
yeah take away the you can take away the
thing that caused it and it lives unto
itself
no now a lot of the reason i'm asking
about the time aspect is because like
imagine a flower then it gives rise to
some pollen well that pollen lives
independent of the flower but the pollen
also at some point dies so i'm one right
okay just because it gives birth it
doesn't mean that it's in depth yeah no
it doesn't mean it's indefinite it means
it needs a certain structure to to
create that
okay
you know i mean
read his the the the piece it's uh yeah
i'll send you a copy of it if you want
please please yeah
it's fascinating again i don't know the
math and a lot of
a lot of physicists
just
dismiss him outright
but as with any of
these uh theories there's a little often
cult-like following of people who you
know are absolutely determined to prove
that he's right in fact the the the
piece is written by somebody else is
writing about
the guy and writing about his findings
and kind of collecting it into a to a
little treat i see i see
gary and i spoke briefly over email
afterward and gary said the following to
me with the caveat of letting the
audience know that this is not what gary
actually thinks is quote unquote true
it's simply interesting mathematics that
expands one's thinking on the matter
look at the last sentence of this
document fascinating emergent property
he claims again i don't know if this is
true or anything it's just fun to think
about the quote is moreover they can
continue to exist autonomous as persona
without material reconnection basically
consciousness or a soul once created can
exist independently what is not explored
in figure 9 of the paper he sets up
humans as the last in the series of
entities that are created through his
physics starting at bio-force bracket
minimal sets of organization of
space-time objects close bracket up
through animals and primates with humans
as the last in the series what might be
next